let's say we're trying to figure out
what 2
divided by
1 10 is so pause this video and see if
you can have a go at that
all right now there's a couple of ways
that we could approach this we could
just try to think of everything in terms
of tenths since we're dividing by one
tenth and so instead of two ones we
could rewrite that two as the same thing
as twenty tenths
twenty tenths
divided by divided by and i could
rewrite this as 1 10.
and so if you have 20 of something and
if you want to divide it into groups of
one of that something how many groups
are you going to have well you're going
to have 20 groups so this is going to be
equal to 20. so it's interesting 2
divided by 1 10
is equal to 20.
now what if i were to take i'm no no i'm
just going to make up another number
let's say if i were to take 7
divided by
divided by 1 10. what is that going to
be equal to
well same idea seven ones is the same
thing as seventy
tenths and if i divide that
by
one
tenth
well seventy of something divided into
groups of one of that something is going
to be 70 equal groups
so this is going to be equal to
70. so 7 divided by 1 10 is equal to 70.
2 divided by 1 10 is equal to 20. you
might notice a pattern now there's other
ways that we could have approached this
we could have said something like
2
divided by 1 10 is the same thing as 2
over
1 10 and i could write 1 10
like that and so when you divide by a
fraction that's the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal so this is
the same thing as
2
times
2 times 10.
and then that pattern might be a little
bit clearer which is going to be equal
to 20. when you divide by a tenth it's
the same thing as multiplying by 10.
same thing happened over here when we
divided by a tenth it was the same thing
as multiplying 7 by 10 to get to 70.
so what do you think is going to happen
if we divide by a hundredth
so let's say i have 6
and i am going to let me make that into
a different color so let's say i have 6
and i want to divide that
by
a hundredth
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
well one way to approach it is we can
express everything in terms of
hundredths
so i really enjoy saying hundredths
hundredths
so six could be rewritten as each whole
is equal to a hundred hundredths so six
wholes or six ones is going to be equal
to six hundred hundredths
so this is going to be equal to
600
hundredths
hundredths
and then that's going to be divided into
equal groups of 100th
hundredth
so if i have 600 of something and i'm
dividing it into equal groups of one of
that something how many equal groups am
i going to have well i'm going to have
600 equal groups
now another way that we could have we
could have approached this is we could
have approached it with fractions we
could have said hey
this thing is the same thing as
6 over 100
which i could express like this
which is equal to
6 times the reciprocal of 100 so that's
6
times the reciprocal of 100 which is 100
over 1 or we could just write that as
100 which once again gets us to 600.
so maybe you're seeing a pattern again
when you divide by a hundredth that's
equivalent to multiplying by a hundred
when you divide by a tenth that's the
equivalent as multiplying by ten
so i'll leave you there encourage you to
think about that so